can we scootch both of us I don't know
I'm scootch I'm a little bit off to the
slide out of context on camera that
sentence would sound very weird just say
no I can meet to you as well
yeah hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alva
I'm Amy Arbor Amy I was like I usually
let people introduce themselves here Amy
are Byrne you guys go check out her
YouTube channel she just launched it
very recently if you guys are finding my
brother Jabby kawaii you will have seen
her on there many a times and now she's
here saying I no longer want to go on
Jamie's channel only Greg's real rejects
channel exact quote she will confirm
that in writing with her signature
people requesting that we check out this
trailer that's an Adam Sandler
do you like Adam Sandler I like comedy
so yes he's Jewish your if you don't
like each other you all know each other
and meet up for your year lead not the
most major holiday what is it probably
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur which are
the new year on the Jewish calendar Rosh
Hashanah is the new year and Yom Kippur
is the day where you basically say I'm
gonna do better it's the day you make
your resolutions I thought those were
food Yom Kippur and Rosh Hashanah could
be holidays not culinary twelve percent
of the audience is Jewish is it
[Laughter]
yeah they don't go off of country they
go on oh my god you're taking so long to
get to the reaction Greg I don't know if
this is a comedy though by the way I
think this is one of his serious bill
[Music]
okay it's definitely gonna be one of
those more serious forms
[Music]
[Music]
I disagree I disagree Gary what is going
on
[Music]
[Music]
please
yeah have a good time
yes damn
this is me this is how I know I just
[ __ ] do they did bring the do you
thing I'm pretty sure the guy who said
that to him sent black Jew power oh so
he's a black let's dive deep into that
shall we
I think I'll talk about the movie at all
they exist saying facts here IMDB says
this is set in the diamond district of
New York City Howard Ratner a jewellery
seller owner that's how you speak by the
way and and dealer to the rich and
famous must find a way to pay
assessments merchandise is taken from
one of his top sellers and girlfriend it
looks great
I am kind of blown away who actually you
know what I heard this was actually wait
a minute I'm remembering this now this
was actually a tiff right okay yeah this
for me that if uncle James reaffirms
uncle chess I think so it's my cousin
uncle James will we calm on the street
uncut gems reaffirmed the safdie's as
masters of anxiety-inducing cinema and
proves Adam Sandler remains a formidable
dramatic actor when given the right
materials Wow Wow I agree just based on
that two minutes we know I've never seen
before you haven't seen any of his
dramatic films no not really I mean
[Laughter]
dramatic it's a little dramatic there
there are tears and I think I did cry
actually but no not really
uh-uh Adam Sandler's dramatic films I've
wanted him to focus more on that because
I'm one of the people who actually gets
a big kick out of his comedy I watched
the the Netflix movie he did with
Jennifer ants
and recently just put it on ran away I
think it's called murder mystery I
thought it was really funny his comedies
are not well-received by critics
obviously he is a solid dramatic actor
if movies like funny people punch-drunk
love the one rain rain on me ran over me
something like that he is a really great
actor and I think this film was excites
me about it as he's doing Adam Sandler
isms that's what you call yeah
charming yelling well I'm just like I
think facial expressions can be his
thing too like in this character I see
that strength of his his favor and he's
someone who seems like you know he wants
to be a much bigger player but he's he's
kind of looked down upon a lot the
character of a character like this shark
ish guy people seem to have a very low
opinion about it it seems like the world
he's surrounded by everyone's is talking
like talking smack on him the whole time
Carrie I thought he carried himself with
a lot of confidence yeah that's what I
find interesting about that kind of
character yeah is someone who doesn't
view it I mean I imagine there's
probably an extra layer where he kind of
views himself a little bit like that but
this was interesting is that we're
watching trailer and it's becoming like
this character study of this one guy I
think it was just so surprising to me to
see him and I mean I'm really excited I
definitely want to see I love idina
menzel who's the woman who plays his
love interest it looks like girlfriend
yeah girlfriend
have you seen wicked wicked no no no
people out there no wicked you have an
insanely popular Broadway show guy I
know what is she doing the original
alphabet oh how interesting okay so she
can sing well let's hope that this movie
takes an inspiration from wicked and
infuses it in here her green face on
again this seems to have like this tense
thriller mood piece about it too I feel
like there's a very specific type of
ticking clock that's happening here I've
seen the Adam Sandler dramatic films but
those are just you know the dramas this
seems to be intense yeah and that's not
something I'm used to seeing Adam
Sandler and I like the dramatic films
were the ones that are a little bit more
taking a look at a guy's life or
something yeah I mean it seems like it's
something of his was stolen and he's
definite
dealing with you know shady characters
who were feeding him up and stuff yes
situations I've been in so many times I
can't tell you speak for yourself I mean
I have I used to have many many more
friends but quality not quantity Greg
that's true sometimes criminals help
lean out some of the unnecessary friends
there were just bad influences on me
even though I got them killed I think
the cinematographer here too is really
cool so good the colors they've got kind
of a bluey pink moody lighting yeah kind
of reflective of them I ready yeah yeah
you can tell the film will have a vibe
it's kind of it's got this like new wash
look yeah but still has a great to it
you know it's like I like films that
have a sort of this really pretty but it
also feels kind of ugly yeah you do okay
ugly pretty is great then then we have a
phrase we can apply to the trailer we
did i'll get fruity ugly pretty I'm
excited for this Rotten Tomatoes score
combined with a great trailer I'm like
yeah I'm probably gonna check this out
cuz here's what I member 25th verse miss
see this is at the peak of award season
people I am sure when the films that are
gonna be considered for stuff are coming
out so maybe Adams he has he's going for
it
get a Netflix deal and the only one
that's like really highly praised is I
haven't seen it yet Matt Maher with
marrow of its storage yeah say that my
hair marrow it's Jewish not that Jewish
I can't say that Garnett is in it and oh
and the weekend as the week and the
weekend Kevin Garnett and the weekend
playing themselves in it Adam sound had
probably called in some favors he knows
a lot of people
Oh interesting
themselves kevin garnett got some
real-time like it wasn't just like oh
and Kevin Garnett will make a
split-second appearance and everyone
who's a fan of him will be happy I have
a bigger role it looks like so curve
ball for him or they were just really
showing him in the trailer or that's the
entirety of his room yeah probably all
right guys well thanks for being here
are you excited for uncut gems is this
how you'll be spending your Christmas
holiday watching Adam Sandler be
dramatic guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
Bell Amy are Byrne check out her YouTube
channel as soon as you can follow her on
Instagram check her out at performing
Mass at your local Catholic Church you
know what that's not going in the video